no one can survive in this world without
help they're too weak to fight you must
be their strength I see my mine
sometimes I wonder if this is the price
for our sins you'll have inherited your
father's responsibilities
I am afraid and they come at a cost this
woman will lead him into a war he cannot
win time has come to choose Joffrey
Renly Robb Stark they're all thieves the
Iron Throne is mine no one wants you for
their king
we are a free and independent Kingdom
power resides where men believe it
resides whatever you need to do it's a
trick you are king a shadow on the wall
and a very small man can cast a very
large shadow
[Music]
if you to answer for your brother's
treason no matter where you sleep
hunt him down this is what ruling is I
understand the way this game is played
nothing matters but our darlings
we'll find you first